confinement fermeture des salles l'année
2020 sera morose pour le cinéma en
france
mais avant cela les français étaient
restés fidèles à l'écran géant 213
millions 300 mille entrées en 2019
des résultats satisfaisants pour la
filière pourtant maintes fois
concurrencé par d'autres écrans retour
dans les années 50
à l'époque chaque année les salles de
cinéma enregistre plus de 300 millions
d'entrées mais une menace arrivait prend
de la place dans nos salons dans les
années 60 c'est le téléviseur sans
télévision la télé fait de l'ombre au
cinéma d'autant qu'à la fin des années
soixante dix il devient possible
d'enregistrer des programmes sur
cassette
si vous gardez cette cassette pour votre
usage personnel
aucun problème en revanche si vous la
vendez aussi vous l'a louée à un ami par
exemple vous êtes devenu un pirate
amateur depuis le développement de la
télé
la fréquentation des salles de cinéma
cette terreau des en 1960 plus de 354
millions de tickets se sont vendus puis
les français ont petit à petit déserté
les salles et en 1992 les entrées ont
chuté à 116 millions le pire score à ce
jour la faute au petit écran mais aussi
aux prix trop élevé selon l'insee
les années suivantes des chiffres
repartent à la hausse poussée par des
super productions spectaculaires sur
écran géant comme titanic en douze jours
3 millions sa semelle entre eux je n'ai
jamais vécu 115 ans de métier dans les
années 2000 un autre écran menace la
fréquentation en salles celui
d'ordinateurs avec internet en haut
débit
les français découvrent le streaming et
le téléchargement tous deux illégaux
les films se copie sur dvd où
s'échangent par clé usb pour autant tous
ne sont pas pessimiste quant à la
fréquentation des salles sortir pour
voir un film pour refaire le monde après
à partir d'un film discuter dans un
petit bistrot dans un café dans un
restaurant ça fait partie de l'art de
vivre la salle de cinéma reste
fédératrice sans doute grâce à une
qualité de son et d'image bien
supérieure à celle des films qui
circulent sur la toile
jusqu'en 2010 le grand écran attire les
spectateurs la barre des 200 millions
est à nouveau dépassée depuis 2010 la
fréquentation des salles se stabilise au
dessus des 200 millions d'entrées
annuelles l'année 2020 sera moins bonne
la photocopie de 19 déjà fin avril la
fédération nationale des cinémas
français estimé les pertes à 300
millions d'euros
les salles sont désormais ouvertes avec
une capacité d'accueil réduite de moitié
pour la majorité des salles
[Musique]